in an example of life imitating art  Nicki Minaj says she's retiring to focus  on having a family mirroring lyrics in  her 2010 song moment for life take a  listen to this put everything that I  tell you with the ring yes no I'm not  lucky I'm blessed  yes so the 10 time Grammy nominated  singer made the announcement on Twitter  yesterday last month Minaj revealed on  her Queen radio show that she planned to  marry boyfriend Kenneth petty in the  coming months yes and jay-z when he  released the black album he was like  this is it works retirement ever works  for sending a message your audience oh I  want to take a break here I might come  back one day but yeah and it appears  like I mean Adele sorta did the same  thing that's right one of the fans  his name is Don Kron on Twitter said  about to look up the word retire  hopefully it means dropping an album  tomorrow